the reason humans should go to Mars is
because we're human I mean we are an
exploring species it's what's made us
the dominant species on this planet if
we only lived in one little plot of land
on earth we never went anywhere I would
say let's explore I need a good reason
to cross this ocean well because we
haven't done it before how's that for a
good reason you might learn something
tomorrow that we don't know today you
know there's an old saying you know what
are you climbing that mountain it's
because it's there because I want to do
that it's what we do we explore as human
beings and so going to Mars it's an
obvious next step it's the great beyond
in the most literal terms right it's the
great VI we humans love a target we love
to have something to shoot for to aim
for and to build a plan to make happen
and Mars has that sexiness that romance
I think it's galvanizing a lot of people
right here right now
for me it's just a curiosity as a human
being I'm curious you know you want to
know what's in beyond that horizon
curiosity has actually fueled most of
the great achievements that we've made
in the world especially through
technology if there's a place you've
never been there's a scientist wants to
know what's there just the curiosity of
inquiry we can understand the evolution
and formation of our own solar system we
can start to understand how planets form
and how they evolve and we can also
start to understand you know the
distribution of life in million
we're looking for life so when you ask
people why are we going to Mars number
one reason is because we're looking for
signs of life elsewhere in the solar
system and imagine if we can find that
there are actually some cells or some
signature of life on Mars that to be a
game-changing in our thinking about our
position in the universe one of the
things that happens when you go into
space and all the astronauts talk about
this is that it changes your perspective
about the earth the human experience of
actually being there will be revelatory
in ways we can't even imagine at this
moment the true ah of hey who are we in
this universe and what can we learn
about it and what can we therefore learn
about ourselves I think is a really
great reason to explore one of the
reasons that I really like is not seeing
Mars as a challenge to overcome but to
see Mars as an opportunity to unite
people together in a peaceful ways we
can give not just ourselves but our
culture and our society and our species
a goal and can unite so many different
types of people together you're actually
addressing fundamental issues on Earth
by giving people something optimistic to
pursue and that's why I want to see us
giving Mars and I want to leave that as
a legacy for my children and for the
next generations of our species
you